les collectionneurs de tintin sont à la
fête aujourd'hui une vente aux enchères
était uniquement consacré aux affiches
album et autres figurines d'hergé les
prêts aussi était à la fête
christophe airaud valérie crétins ce ne
sont pas du tout les soldes juste
quelques dizaines de teintes à magnac
réunis pour une vente aux enchères un
petit côté grand bazar des bustes des
insupportables du pont jusqu aux
éditions originales de 1930 pour relire
l'oreille cassée vous débourserez vingt
mille francs
et pour vous êtes jugé tata au pays des
soviets il vous faudra vendre les bijoux
de la castafiore cet album de 1930 qui
est le premier album qu'hergé à dessiner
s'agit d'un tirage de tête qui a été
fait à 500 exemplaires il nous reste une
petite vingtaine sur le marché
aujourd'hui connue au niveau du prix cet
album devrait battre le record du monde
cet après midi et nous commençons à 100
milles alors ça en prend comprend 135
milles 140 milles 198 monsieur debout
205000 monsieur bout de 110000 à 210000
le record du monde est battue l'acheteur
était discret alors pour comprendre le
passionné
rien ne vaut un collectionneur belge
j'ai 52 ans donc ça le monde mac
maxime jeunesse et on essaie de
retrouver les albums qu'on avait quand
on était jeunes et en plus
l'album est plus que jamais que moi
certains repartiront avec un souvenir de
leur enfance perdue d'autres avec une
oeuvre qui est aussi devenu spéculatifs
pour 2 millions 600 mille francs de
ventes